هذا العام بالذات همم عينينا همم نتيجه
تقلب المناخ همم النحل صار في هلاك نحل
كثير في قطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
السنه كانت اسوا سنه على النحالين همم صار
في انهيران انهيار في الخلايا الخليه
اليوم 10 براويز بعد اسبوع نلاقيها اربعه
بعدين يلاقيها بروازين تموت الخليه ليش
لانه النحل متاقلم على انه في حر همم يكون
في برد متاقلم انه في برد جاي ضلت الدنيا
حر عليه فصار الدربكه صارت عنده خربطه في
المنظومه بتاعه النحل
[موسيقى]
كانت الظروف المناخيه خلال العام الماضي
لم تكن مواطن عمليه انتاج عسل جيده خلال
شهر يعني نيسان ومايو وهي الفتره التي
دائما يعتمد عليها النحل الخروج وجمع
الرحيق يعني
تخزين هذا العسل داخل الصناديق كانت
الظروف المناخيه غير مواتيه درجات الحراره
انخفضت منخفضت جويه متتاليه ادت الى عدم
خروج النحل الى الخارج بل ويعني استهلاك
ما هو موجود داخل الخليه الامر الذي ادى
الى ضعف شديد في الانتاجيه الخاصه
[موسيقى]
كميات النحل لما صارت تقلد هذا طبعا
الادور علينا في
العلاج بالاضافه الى هيك منتجات النحل مش
بس العسل
النحل وما شابه برضو صار فيها يعني تاثرت
كثير من خلال هذه التاثيرات